most people only pay attention to the
final product of a successful
entrepreneur they say things like I can
never be like them or they got lucky
what most don't see is what they've
overcome
all the struggles the daily rejections
the heartaches the betrayals the rumors
the criticism the empty bank account and
all those lonely nights while trying to
make their vision a reality you see the
only difference between the one who
quits and the one who doesn't is that
they showed up every day they worked
hard every day they hustled every day
they learned from a proven mentor every
day they improve every day they did all
this even though they felt like quitting
every day and eventually they became who
they are today
you